>> Sandra: FOX NEWS ALERT.
SHEDDING LIGHT ON HOW LONG THE
VIRUS CAN LIVE ON SURFACES.
SCIENTISTS DISCOVERING THAT THEY
CAN REMAIN DETECTABLE FOR
SEVERAL HOURS OR EVEN DAYS IN
SOME CASES.
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES WITH WHAT WE
NEED TO KNOW.
>> YOU DON’T WANT TO GET THIS OR
GIVE IT TO OTHERS.
HERE’S WHAT THE GOVERNMENT STUDY
FOUND ON THE CORONAVIRUS.
SAY A PERSON SNEEZES OR COUGHS.
AT THE VIRUS STAYS AIRBORNE AT
HIGH LEVELS BUT DETECTABLE FOR
THREE HOURS BEFORE THE AEROSOL
DROPLETS QUALITY SERVICES WHERE
IT CAN SURVIVE IN CARDBOARD UP
TO 24 HOURS, STAINLESS STEEL,
TWO DAYS, PLASTIC FOR THREE.
>> HARD SURFACES NOT SHOWN IN
FABRIC AS MUCH OR IN CARDBOARD,
BUT HARD SERVICE TRANSMISSION.
>> THE VIRUS REMAINS
COMMUNICABLE, BUT THE RISK
DECLINES OVER THE TIME FRAME AS
IT DIES OFF.
THE TAKE AWAY, BE CAREFUL AT
HOME IN THE PUBLIC.
ESPECIALLY IF SOMEONE IS
INFECTED.
>> PEOPLE SHOULD RECOGNIZE THAT
LIVING WITH THIS THING MEANS
THAT THERE IS A 35% ATTACK RATE
THAT IS A CHANCE THAT SOMEONE
ELSE FROM THE HOUSE GETS THE
VIRUS BECAUSE ONE PERSON IN THE
HOUSE HAS IT.
>> BEST PRACTICE IS TO KEEP
EVERYTHING CLEAN.
REFRIGERATOR, MICROWAVE, TV
REMOTE, AND COUNTERTOPS.
USE LONG STROKES AND WIPE IN
ONLY ONE DIRECTION.
>> MOST PEOPLE GRAB A TOWEL AND
THEY MOVE IN MULTIPLE
DIRECTIONS, AND THEY’RE ACTUALLY
PUSHING AND PULLING SOIL BACK
ONTO A SURFACE.
THINK ABOUT PUSHING SNOW.
YOU ARE ALWAYS PLOWING IN ONE
DIRECTION.
DO THE SAME THING WHEN YOU ARE
WIPING OFF THE COUNTER.
>> IN PUBLIC, DOLLARS, COINS,
PATHOGENS, GAS PUMPS, ELEVATOR
BUTTONS.
YOU GET THE PICTURE, SANDRA.
SOAP AND WATER, COMMERCIAL